so we're very protective of our energy
here at Grove HQ because
because there are people who want to
constantly take take a little bit of
that but give nothing back in return
they're my vampires
so we're taking this to the dark
dancehall realms
as we say
yeah
little Vibes energy and we go
and we say
we go vampire blood sucker you want to
take my energy but now you're plastic
Wheels
[Music]
on the skin when it's all fully charged
wouldn't sneak through the hearts
we take the reins of the horse on the
bluff to the promises
get a little closer we turned black and
queer Liberation is
[Music]
blood sucker we had no time for the
blood sucker take away energy only one
Good Vibes when we turn up in this
is
[Music]
clock
it's the promise
blood sucker be 100 times
[Music]
blood sucker
what's up
[Applause]
[Music]
give it up for the big bad EJ Akin
[Applause]